the annual dice awards have been held
since 1998 and the big winners of the
19th anniversary were revealed the night
of februari 18th the full list of
winners is up on gamespot com but we'll
highlight some of the big ones right
here Bethesda's fallout 4 took home
overall game of the year but it also won
role playing game of the year and
outstanding achievement and game
direction indie darling or in the blind
forest also one in three big categories
taking home outstanding achievement in
animation art direction and music
composition The Witcher 3 and rocket
League also took home three wins each as
for industry figures Metal Gear creator
Hideo Kojima was inducted into the Hall
of Fame and Nintendo's Satoru wada
received a posthumous Lifetime
Achievement Award there were plenty of
winners but if you're interested in the
full dice summit we've got much more up
on gamespot you can check out words from
Bethesda's todd howard plus our own
interview with a day Okajima for all of
that gaming news and more you're
definitely in the right place